well i've just talked to uh ursula von
de leon and
updated the cabinet about the contents
of the call
and the idea was that when we went out
on wednesday the hope was that we were
going to be able to
finish things off on today if there was
a deal
to be done as things stand
and this was basically what ursula and i
agreed i'm afraid we're still
very far apart on some key things but
where there's life
there's hope we're going to keep uh
talking to see what we can do the uk
certainly won't be
uh walking away from the talks i think
people would expect us to to go the
extra mile
i repeated my my offer which is you know
if it's necessary to talk to other
capitals and i'm very happy to do that
the commission very determined to keep
the thing and keep the negotiations on
uh the way that they be done between us
and the commission you know
that that's that's fine but i've got to
repeat the
most likely thing now is of course that
uh we have to get ready for
wto terms australia terms and don't
forget
everybody we've made huge preparations
for this we've now been at this for
four and a half years sam you know uh
there's a long time perhaps more
intensively in the last couple of years
than previously
but anyway uh we've got ready um and
anybody who needs to know
what to do get onto gov dot uk forward
slash
transition see what needs to be done and
get ready for january the first and
either way whatever happens the uk will
do very
very well now you've always said you
needed to see
political movement from the eu
have you seen any at all centimeters
millimeters of political movement in the
last
few days sam we are always happy to
to talk and to make progress where we
can
i do think as i say there is a deal to
be done
if our partners want to do it
but we remain very far apart on these
key
issues and you know what they they are
the uk can't be locked into the
eu's regulatory orbit uh and we've
obviously got to
take back control of our fisheries uh
you know four and a half years after
people
uh voted for it so those are the those
are the points i think that
uh you know it's very clear what the uk
uh is talking about
uh let's let's see what we can achieve
but in the meantime
get ready with confidence for january
the first
trade on wto terms if we have to if you
listen
just to ursula uh vondeline the european
commission president's statement today
you would think that no deal was
slightly less
likely is that is that a fair reading
she was a bit more optimistic than
you'll
be look i mean i don't want to look if
if ursula is
optimistic then that's great uh because
you know we want to we but you know as
far as i can see there are
there are there are some seriousness and
very
very very difficult issues that uh
currently separate the
uh the the uk from the eu and
uh the best thing to do now for
everybody
is to follow up all the work that's been
done uh over the last
four and a half years colossal amount of
preparation
at our ports everywhere across the uk
get ready to trade on
wto terms and there is a there is a
clarity and a simplicity
in uh in that approach uh that you know
has its own
advantages it's not where we wanted to
get to
but if we have to end up with that
solution the uk
is more than prepared bottom line is
you won't say there's been political
progress from the eu
but you won't say that there hasn't been
what i'll
say is i think that uh the uk should
continue to try and i think that's what
the people of this country would want me
to do
we're going to continue to try and we're
going to try with all our hearts and
we'll be as creative as we possibly can
but what we can't do
is compromise on that fundamental
nature of what brexit is all about which
is us being able to control our laws
control our fisheries it's very very
simple i think our friends get it
and uh you know we we remain willing to
talk we'll continue
to do so but in the meantime let's get
ready for
the wto option and that's what i told
the cabinet
you